all right so diving in what is it about
nimona that for you to this project got
everything I mean no it's a cop-out
answer but the original Source material
so cool so beloved so imaginative the
character felt so relatable to my own
experience and so many peoples the cost
you know
um what Chloe's done in this in Eugene
all these people have just been just the
top of the game but really I say maybe
that
the thing that pulled it all together is
our amazing directors Troy and Nick they
just I mean most of us recorded on our
own and and while we were doing that
Troy and Nick played every other
character for everyone you know they're
just so committed playful meticulous
they're stamina their enthusiasm is just
endless so when you're working with
people like it just inspires you and
from the first meeting I could I could
get that passion from them
um
and and so yeah that I think they drew
drew me to the project and everything
they were presenting and everything they
were pulling together
was exciting no I know like this is
based on a graphic novel and baluster
obviously had this he existed in some
form already but did you get the chance
to kind of work with the directors with
the writers to expand him beyond what
was already on the page no I can't claim
any credit for that I mean Nick and Troy
are already just like pushing every
single moment in this film to try and
get everything they can from it to try
and deepen it try and make it funnier
try and make it more surprising
um I was really just kind of like in
their hands and you know trying to
understand their vision for it and and
do my best to kind of hit that Mark and
then they'd also encourage me to
improvise and try things and play around
so that was more moment to moment in
terms of the overall Arc and the vision
of the character I was in safe hands
that knew that they would always push
for everything that they could if
they're like a standout moment of improv
that like comes to mind when you think
back to the recording it's all a blur it
took place over about four years at this
point but I know if it's improv or not
but I love that moment when when Mona
just says that guy peed in his armor
that guy peed in his armor
um
what
um so many amazing lines I think Chloe's
done an incredible job in this so no
spoilers but is there a moment in the
film you know beyond like The Comedy of
it but is there a specific moment that
you are most excited for people to
um to experience when they see the movie
honestly it's it's not a specific moment
but I just want people to meet pneumonia
and fall in love with her like I said I
think what Chloe's done with this
character is just phenomenal I think
nimona to begin with is a hugely lovable
hilarious mischievous character I think
this could be just one of people's
favorite animation characters of all
time I I genuinely feel like that she
certainly is one of my favorites
straight away do you speak very highly
of pneumonia she's an awesome character
and I think her and baluster is dynamic
throughout the whole thing it's the
heart of the story so I wonder if you
could speak to kind of what it was like
bringing that that Dynamic to life it
was interesting because like I said we
were often recording solos so we were
relying a lot on Nick and Troy to do the
you know other characters but
what's amazing is that um
you know when I did get to hear what
Chloe was doing when he could see what
she was inspiring the animators to do
like the force of her performance and of
pneumonia's character just Shone through
and
you know when you're working with people
that good and with writing and
characters and directors they're good
honestly it's like
you kind of just have to
just respond you know to what you're
given
um don't get me wrong it's a real
workout they put me through my Paces I
wasn't just chilling out and just
banging the ball back but they would not
let me coast and be like yeah I think we
got that line they're like no do it 50
more times do it this way this way this
way this way so you know my first time
doing animation
um but uh it just felt like
um
it felt like playing around with friends
you know would you say that was maybe
the biggest challenge in making it is
because if it's your first animated
project kind of
getting into the swing of a new way of
doing things yeah I think so this is a
new process really and it's just like
it's really physical it's quite can be
quite Technical and it's very very long
detailed process you know you record
everything then you come back and do it
again and then you go back and you come
and do it again and the animation the
story and everything is just evolving
again and again it's like a back and
forth between what you're recording and
what's being animated
for literally years I think three or
four years at this point you know so um
there's something kind of really
inspiring about that
um commitment that it takes to make it
and it's certainly I have even more
respect for animators after this